[Applause]
all right after president Trump's
address on the border the Democratic
Party sent out sent out these two
carnival cutouts as a rebuttal
oh that's missing with the beanbags to
toss through their pie holes talk about
stiff are we sure this wasn't a subtle
promotion for the new season of The
Walking Dead brought to you by the
makers of formaldehyde it's odorless
tasteless but keeps you in government
for decades look at him now I'm not
talking about how they look that's too
easy it's just how they are like a
couple of greeters at cigar world old
people get that you want a wall that's a
wall there's they are so rigid they make
Mike Pence look like this guy
[Music]
to be that lawn but it makes you wonder
what were they thinking on the very
first day of this Congress House
Democrats passed Senate Republican
legislation where am i straight ahead
border security solutions should I have
worn my glasses but they tickle my nose
that's which would reopen government why
did she get to speak first she always
does I hate her to waste billions of
dollars and I've been her hair I paid a
lot for it a wall he always promised
plus I'm a senator so I get to stand on
the little wooden box do you know many
squirrels it took to make this weed
hostage critical services I love
squirrels they've big fluffy tails one
covers my bald spots
true now if you're looking for proof of
how truly screwed up government is look
no further
Trump's address wasn't earth-shattering
he colored within the lines he stuck to
the facts even repeating the same points
the Democrats and the media had stated
before still it didn't matter the media
was giddy with fact-checking
fact checkers eat your Wheaties today
yeah we'll be fact-checking relentlessly
they have to have real-time
fact-checking setting the scene for an
address that will test the fact checkers
later on tonight oh they're so excited
they're like great school kids around
free ice cream or Kevin Spacey at a
high-school wrestling match but but when
the time came there wasn't much to
fact-check the crime stats were legit
the number of kids abandoned factual the
anecdotes Trump listed sadly were all
too real which is why they had to
redefine fact-checking
as disgruntled commentary seriously I
wonder what they were thinking we
address you tonight for one reason only
I could really go for a hoagie with ham
cheese onions lettuce pickles some
mustard and unable to convince a straw
me salami
tomatoes no no tomatoes more cheese the
cheese with holes
we don't govern by temper tantrum why
does cheese have holes seems like a
ripoff
talk about cheese with holes oh god what
is that smell
Oh Chuck not again he's just deadly see
a doctor please I think something's dead
inside you and of course the media made
fools of themselves pretending there is
no crisis when just weeks before they
were calling it a crisis themselves
remember the caravan wasn't that a
crisis not anymore
the big scam of the whole address was
that there's a crisis there's not a
crisis the President's speech was a
litany of scare stories about immigrants
being terrible criminals this is a
crisis that he wants you to believe is
worth shutting down a manufactured
crisis so that address probably should
have come with a surgeon general's
warning it was hazardous to the truth
you know that it costs to practice that
line in front of a CNN bathroom mirror
and Don Don lemons like killer lie Jim
don't forget to flush but damn if Jimmy
doesn't make Trump's points for him here
are some of the steel slats that the
president's been talking about right
here as we're walking along here we're
not seeing any kind of imminent danger
there are no migrants trying to rush
toward this fence here in the McAllen
Texas area no sign of the national
emergency that the president has been
talking about as a matter of fact it's
pretty tranquil down here okay so here I
am in front of a wall and there are no
illegals crossing it
some people some people some people
might call that cause and effect but not
Jim they have nothing to do with each
other you know he should do more of this
you know Here I am holding an umbrella
in the rain and my god I am dry clearly
if there's no rain now when I put on
these sunglasses suddenly the sun's
glare is gone obviously the Sun has gone
missing but I wonder if Trump
appreciated the sales pitch appreciate
you
[Laughter]
oh my god I don't care I don't care what
you think of Trump you could put him on
Rushmore for that alone as for poor Jim
that wasn't even the worst part of his
week yesterday man who promised with
your own shoes nothing about the truth
you gotta to make sure that goes viral
this is why by the way this is why I'm
one of the only people around here
moving through the time of day let me
get back in your face cuz you're such a
smartass at the time these people go but
let me just be respectful to the media
at large as I always am I explain the
gutless alternative information
additional facts and I explain it many
times and don't you put it back in my
face for all the corrections at your
networking issue I have a public service
announcement and now a public service
announcement if you happen to come
across too fleshy prune sized orbs
rolling down Pennsylvania Avenue please
put them on ice and promptly returned
them to Jim Acosta this has been a
public service announcement
so the crisis is now a circus how did
this happen well we know that the media
makes everything worse including even
politics which is already the worst
thing ever politics is the invisible gas
that seeps into any discussion removing
nuance and compromise and replacing both
with what I call the prison of two ideas
and each side must pick their cell and
never leave so even if Chuck agreed with
Trump on immigration just a few years
ago it doesn't really matter he's got to
stay in a Cell and the media makes it
worse by turning these prisons into
business models there's no way MSNBC or
the New York Times can make any money if
Chuck and Nancy agree with Trump
compromise doesn't sell advertising
meanwhile this is all made possible by
two years of peace and prosperity
seriously the only way we can endure
this kind of idiotic malfeasance is if
all the big stuff is taken care of jobs
terror economy because Trump has gone
down his list and ticked off all the big
things the Dems can afford to indulge
this lunacy holding workers hostage and
pretending walls or some amoral
phenomenon that Trump's somehow just
invented it's quite a spectacle it makes
you hate our government it makes you
want to turn off the news and God forbid
go talk to your family most of all it
makes you see things as they really are
or rather who they really are and what
they're really thinking he promised to
keep government shutdown for months or
years
where am I am I still here we should be
home by now the Greg Gutfeld show is on
vo this has a good take on things
borders while honoring our values sure
he can be rude but I usually find him to
be spot-on in his analysis Afghanistan
technology it's a shame they canceled
Sarah Silverman show maybe she can get a
job writing for Greg Gutfeld
this little trade what's that smell does
that mean I got to get out of here
look out blue
[Applause]